although most of the devil all the times
interwoven plot points have been wrapped
up by the end of the film
viewers may still leave with some
questions about what they just watched
including what it's all supposed to mean
here are some of the things we're
thinking about after watching the devil
all the time
the first person to speak in the devil
all the time as someone who's never seen
or named he sets the stage for the film
and quickly explains the meaning of the
title
he came every morning and evening to
talk to god
it seemed to his son that his father
fought the devil all the time
this narrator continues to chime in
throughout the rest of the film tying
the seemingly disparate stories together
and commenting on the character's
motivations doubts and innermost
thoughts
as a matter of fact the narrator is the
book's author donald ray pollock
in his director's statement that
accompanied screeners of the film
antonio campos explained
i wanted to use a narrator to tell the
story and build a world in which we gave
a voice to the creator
in a film that strongly centers on
themes of faith and religion creator can
have two meanings
first as the book's author the literal
creator of the story
and second as an omnipotent god
character who comments on the story
through an all-knowing yet detached lens
pollock's inclusion as the narrator
feels almost like a meta commentary on
the faith of the characters
showing that someone is indeed listening
to their desperate prayers
and that it's actually the same
individual who put them in their
harrowing circumstances to begin with
protagonist arvind russell is orphaned
at a young age when his mother is
abruptly felled by cancer and his father
kills himself immediately after her
funeral
before his father dies he takes arvin
with him to watch him attack the men who
had earlier threatened to attack his
wife
arvin takes his brutal lesson in revenge
to heart and carries it with him for the
rest of his life
he beats up the school bullies that
routinely harass his adopted sister
lenora
and then executes preston t garden the
twisted preacher whose abuse leads to
her death
killing teagarden sets off a chain
reaction of violence as arvin flees the
scene of the crime only to be picked up
by serial killers carl and sandy
arvin kills the couple in self-defense
but is pursued by sandy's brother
corrupt sheriff lee beaudeker who is
determined to cover up his sister's
crimes and safeguard his reputation
arvind winds up killing beaudecker as
well and ultimately hitches a new ride
to cincinnati
as he rides away he considers one day
going back home and making amends with
his grandmother
starting a family of his own or
enlisting to fight in the vietnam war
we don't know which of these paths arvin
ultimately takes or if he'll be able to
break the cycle of violence that's
followed him his whole life
at the end of the devil all the time
libo decker's determination to hunt down
and kill arvin doesn't feel motivated by
brotherly grief over the killing of his
sister but by fear
what is beau decker so afraid of well
pretty much everything
bodaker has been chasing money and power
since the first time we met him and
spending his time as sheriff taking
bribes and cutting deals
in the final act of the film bodecker is
running for re-election and is terrified
that the skeletons in his closet could
come spilling out
at first bodecker is just afraid that
his political opponent will discover
that he's been taking bribes and
greasing the wheels for local corrupt
business owners
or that he's been looking the other way
while his sister engages in illegal sex
work
before arvin ever crosses his path he's
already committed two murders to try to
cover up his tracks
but the deaths of sandy and carl lead
beaudeker to uncover their secret stash
of photographs of their victims
rather than do his duty and report what
he's found vodecker destroys the
evidence terrified that if sandy's
activities come to light it will cost
him the election and all the money and
power that comes with it
arvind remains the one loose end a
witness to sandy and carl's crimes
even though arvin has no intention of
sticking around bodecker is determined
to make sure he can never reveal what he
knows about sandy
unfortunately for him arvin is quicker
on the draw and bodecker's paranoia and
lust for power winds up being his
downfall
we get a lot of clues throughout the
devil all the time that sandy is
considering leaving her husband and
abandoning their life of murder and
secrecy
she gets as far as loading up her car
and preparing to drive off but has
second thoughts and returns home
later right before she's killed she even
considers killing carl and driving off
with arvin
but it turns out that carl had grown
distrustful of sandy going so far as to
replace the bullets in her gun with
blanks which is how arvin's life is
spared and sandy's is lost
but would sandy actually have left had
she remained alive we'll never know but
several signs point to no
first of course is the fact that she
didn't leave when she had the chance
of course that doesn't mean she never
would have gone through with it but the
fact that she never takes any of the
opportunities presented to her seemed to
indicate that while she liked the idea
of leaving she wasn't necessarily
determined to actually do it
but the biggest indicator that she would
have stayed is that she actually enjoys
what she and carl do together
before sheriff bodecker visits her house
we see her looking fondly at the photos
of her and carl's victims showing that
she's not just going along with the
murders for his sake she actually gets
pleasure from it herself
as tired as she is of carl she doesn't
seem to be able to give up the killing
which makes her marriage to him a
necessary evil
as arvin hitchhikes away from knock em
stiff at the end of the film a snippet
of an address from president johnson
plays on the radio
justifying his decision to send more
troops to vietnam
that we cannot be defeated by force of
arms
or by superior power while one could
dismiss the speech as background chatter
the quote that made its way into the
film feels significant in a variety of
ways
after all arvin's story began with
another war with his father returning
from world war ii haunted by his
memories of what he experienced
willard's background as a soldier
largely informed the way he parented
arvin
and how he taught him how to solve his
problems with violence then there's the
choice johnson is making to commit more
troops to fighting the war and his
declaration that the united states won't
be strong-armed into backing down
this echoes willard's philosophy about
how to deal with aggressors
them boys might be bigger than you but
the next time one of them starts his
i want you to finish it it's a belief
arvin carries with him long after his
father
is gone which is what drives him to
attack lenora's bullies and the preacher
who abused her
yet at the end of the film as johnson
speaks arvin gives a tremendous yawn and
begins to drift off and dream of a
better life
perhaps this symbolizes that he's
managed to let go of this violent
philosophy
at last and that it no longer holds
power over him
in his director's statement antonio
campos says that one of the things that
drew him to adapt the devil all the time
is its exploration of generational faith
and the elements of religion that get
passed down from parent to child the
director explains that he was raised by
a devout mother and a disillusioned
father
and that rather than having his film
serve as an indictment of faith in
religion he views this story as a way to
explore it
campos writes like the characters in the
story i've inherited a little bit of
both my parents extremes and over the
last several years i've tried to
understand these two extremes within me
i still struggle with my faith and
continue to question it and as a
filmmaker i use storytelling to find
answers
that struggle is clear in the devil all
the time with many of the film's
characters motivated or manipulated
according to their strong religious
convictions
it doesn't shy away from the many ways
in which religion can be twisted to
cause harm
but it also leaves the door open for the
existence of god and some sort of larger
divine plan
speaking to esquire campos said the film
plays with two ideas
one that things are random because
there's the absence of god throughout
the movie but also the way that
everything plays out suggests there is a
bigger force at play
the movie is trying to explore human
beings on earth struggling to connect
and see god
showing there is some greater design but
they can't see it part of this greater
design could be the surprising ways in
which the characters lives intersect for
example serial killers carl and sandy
meet on the same day in the very same
diner where arvid's parents meet
carl and sandy go on to kill lenora's
father leading her to live with arvin's
grandmother which is how arvin and
lenora wind up his siblings
arvin ultimately kills carl and sandy
after avenging lenora none of them even
realize how their fates all trace back
to the same day in the diner all those
years ago
running parallel to the themes of faith
and religious fanaticism and the devil
all the time is the theme of how giving
into violence always begets more
violence
according to campos the devil all the
time is a generational story about the
cyclical pattern of violence
the story is very simply about what we
inherit and what we pass on
this pattern becomes extremely apparent
in arvin who follows closely in his
father's footsteps and how he deals with
threats to his family
even when arvin decides to walk away
from his life after killing the preacher
violence follows him and three more
people are dead by the end of the film
people who are all brought into arvind's
orbit due to violent cycles of their own
it's no coincidence that the narrative
of the film is sandwiched between two
wars
both of which left deep scars on history
at the end of the film with arvin
dreaming of either starting a new life
or enlisting in the war the film seems
to imply that there may be no escaping
this brutal cycle
but that it's worth trying anyway
overall the devil all the time is a
pretty bleak story with a vast majority
of its characters meeting rather
miserable and bloody ends
but against all odds arvin manages to
survive and head off to seek a fresh
start
although we'll never know if he's
actually successful at the ending of the
film campo said
things just have a way of sorting
themselves out and knock them stiff and
even if you don't get a happy ending
there's still the potential for a better
beginning
this seems to speak directly to arvin's
story which culminates in a series of
unlikely encounters which appeared a nod
to divine intervention
maybe it's the very improbability of
arvin's ending that speaks to hope for a
better future
after all the odds of arvin crossing
paths with the same people who met in
the same room as his parents and killed
his sister's father don't seem very high
nor to the odds of him surviving that
encounter perhaps the point of arvind's
story is to show that sometimes
people can beat the odds and break out
of harmful cycles no matter how deeply
entrenched they are
in that sense maybe the ending of the
film isn't quite so bleak after all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite
movies and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one